sabia vous menthe à l'eau de la chaîne
du mental blog il ya quelques temps je
vous avais fait ma troisième trou story
j'avais dit que s'ils ont dépassé les
12000 pouce en l'air on en refait une
autre et ça a été un vitesse incroyable
je ne sais pas à combien je vais devoir
me le quota pour la prochaine parce que
j'ai pas tant d'histoires que ça dans ma
vie non plus mais le fait est que
promesses annoncées promesses tenues et
aujourd'hui je suis avec philippe roche
c'est la quatrième fois que tu viens sur
la chaîne
normal c'est un pote comme celles qui
passent quasiment ont fait une vidéo 4 3
4 4
je suis pas mentaliste peut être 3 ou 4
je sais plus en tout cas celle que je
préfère c'est celle où tu m'apprends
faire des imitations je vous la met en
fiche juste ici regardez là après allez
rigoler donc aujourd'hui philippe et
passe à la maison on regarde aller
manger ensemble et je lui ai dit allez
on n'a pas une histoire marrante a
raconté déjà que tu étais dans la
dernière true story qu'il n'a pas
regardé dans l'avant-dernière douleur
mais avant dernier c'est quand on était
en ukraine a mais des gens ont vu je
sais pas quels secteurs de la gazette le
clown qui regardent ce qui t'as qu'à
regarder la chaîne aussi mots nous mes
meilleures amies ne regarde pas la
chaîne est lancée faut et on est on est
constamment avec toi c'est juste que bon
on peut pas non plus te dire qu'on est
tout le temps avec toi tu comprends il
faut vous pouvez vous référer aux vidéos
sur le mensonge pour voir ce qu'il est
en train d'essayer de me faire moi
j'avais un souvenir particulier j'étais
demandé l'autorisation de le raconter
n'est ce pas mais je te le donne et
débuterait franchement tu m'as dit
direct non encore c'est parce qu'à un
moment donné c'est sûr que ça peut créer
une image un peu fausse 1 du personnage
oui c'est vrai ça avait cinq fois oui
voilà rappelle alors c'est arrivé qu'une
seule fois
alors il ya quelques années je le sais
pas combien de temps ça fait quatre ans
cinq ans huawei 54 5 ans j'avais tu
m'arrête quand je dis des bêtises justin
jarring date sur avignon c'était avignon
lyon
non oui c'est un jeune vigneron à
l'union c'était avignon c'était une
exceptionnelle je crois que je faisais
là bas et après on a un peu traîné à
rentrer puisque on est allés chez ton
cousin et il était déjà une heure très
avancée de la matinée à il était 4h 5h
et je suis promené en train vers 6h30
alex en tout cas c'était avant 7 heures
et ce train était très important parce
que j'avais un rendez vous derrière à
paris que je pouvais pas rater ou non
même pas pire que ça exactement mais
j'avais déjà vu jamais content
ll fallait que je repasse par paris pour
repartir sur le contrat exact à angers
bon tout simplement en fait on se dit on
ne va pas dormir ça c'est sem c'est
parce que sinon voilà mais bon on va pas
se réveiller et donc je connais la
région comme ma poche vous donc à partir
de ce moment là on a subi leur pays et
le chemin fait à peu près 25 minutes
donc en bon sudiste un quart d'heure
c'est bon moi je me fie à lui un
copilote quoi tu vas donc pour le train
à 6 heures 30 on peut partir à 6 heures
on est large
parce que je connais des chemins de
campagne mais bon je les connais deux
jours et d'autre de nuit et ce qui fait
qu'à un moment donné on est sérieusement
en retard et g comment des drames direct
g comment ce drame commence parce que
j'arrive dans un axe qui est sûr et cet
axe dette était en travaux et donc si je
me plante de voix je nous mets 10 km
dans la vue et il nous reste 12 minutes
avant l'arrivée de contrat et ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'il commence à
être très fatigué mais c'est pas tant
que tu es picoler d'ailleurs je souhaite
enfin en tout cas on avait picolé il
était genre 23h donc la 6 heures du
matin s'est déroulée oui mais mais c'est
que tu es fatigué il est papa en plus
sain il se lève tôt si oui parce que ça
j'adore c'est l'avion parce qu'il est
papa donc igol payet très bien et je
connais philippe collet comme ça quand
ils commencent à perdre patience et je
vois quand même que la [ __ ] de travaux
de merde
bon moi je dis rien peu par lâcheté
principalement comme très agaçant
d'arriver dans une ville que tu connais
bien et qui mettent des travaux comme ça
sans déviation est pas marqué déviation
surtout que depuis 24 heures et je
connais la ville comme ma poche mon pote
et je serai bien fait ce que je vois et
on vend on est parti vers nîmes
au lieu de partir vers avignon
concrètement c'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé de quoi ça devait arriver à
avignon je te fais prendre la direction
il y avait deux directions à prendre il
n'y avait pas de déviation donc je
prends celle où il ya des travaux et à
partir de ce moment là je vais direction
nîmes
mais moi oui c'est je ne te le dis pas
parce que tout ce que tu me dises et je
te demande toujours le timing oui je dis
combien de temps combien de temps ça le
faire ça le faire ça me faire ça à le
faire et donc je me souviens qu'il y a
un petit passage qui me permettrait de
faire un demi tour
sous le sous le pont le pont de l'europe
et ce passage avant les travaux étaient
praticables en dans le bon sens du terme
il n'y a pas de problème tout et je
connais un autre chemin ils tracent des
petites rues moi je commence gentiment à
sortir mon iphone pour chercher google
maps et essayer de voir en temps réel si
c'est les bonnes directions pas et toi
tu as je reconnais pas ça je me suis dit
ça je reconnais pas là je reconnais rien
même ils ont vraiment changer les
panneaux
sauf qu'il ya un moment donné à cet
endroit là je savais que je pouvais
tourner à droite donc machinalement je
tourne à droite et là il tend la droite
alors je ralentis un peu de cette story
puisque effectivement on est un endroit
où l'on reconnaît pas où il ya les
panneaux de change et j'en sais rien moi
je grossis sur une route et il tourne à
droite et moi je prends conscience de
quelque chose vous le dis juste après et
là philippe est très stressé parce qu'il
veut pas que georges le train un peu
énervé de tout ce qui se passe est très
fatigué parce qu il est 6 heures et
quelques du matin et mon train et dans
quelques minutes
et donc je calme un peu le jeu et je
fais philippe est ce que tu peux
t'arrêter s'te plaît mais vraiment avec
cette voix là quoi passe temps à toucher
non mais vraiment arrête toi je te dis
un truc et arrête toi une seconde balle
a pas le temps je te plait ça
sérieusement mon pote juste voilà sur le
bas côté et tu t'arrêtes je vais enfin
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un [ __ ] on est déjà
là pour cheveux ras il se passe qu'on
est en train de rentrer sur l'autoroute
à contresens
est ce que j'avais repéré c'est quand à
tourner à droite je voyais tous les
panneaux qui nous faisait dos ça tu sais
c'était c'était une petite honte à une
voie rapide
oui mais du coup ça va oui et puis
surtout que bon un moment donné ils ont
changé tous les panneaux de sens et ça
ne voulait rien dire je suis passé cent
fois dans ma jeunesse jusqu'à ce sur ce
panneau mon argent tu passe sous le pont
est bien là là on passe pas sous le pont
la région le voie rapide bon tu
peut-être qu'ils ont orné les panneaux
sens on ne les voyait pas puisqu'il
était doit nous puisqu'on allaient dans
le mauvais sens tu sais c est ce qu on
appelle la voie de décélération en fait
quand tu sors de la voie rapide
bon après peut-être que tu connais mieux
que moi que tu sais que la personne
master 6 et plus rapide de prendre à
contre sens cinq ans plus tard je peux
te le dire bonne nouvelle j'ai quand
même bientôt passer mon permis
je passais souvent dans ce coin-là en
scooter s'est du coup pour moi je
connaissais tous par coeur
oui mais c'était cette norme bon moi
c'est le jour où je rigole je ponds il
ya le pont d'avignon il aura d'ailleurs
j'ai cru que j'allais mourir ne te le
dis ça mais non mais en vrai ce jour là
j'ai compris comment ça arrive et qu'il
y en ait qui se retrouve hors sens
inverse sur l'autoroute
généralement ils ont 80 ans passés et
meet up avec 80 g passation ou quoi
toujours une histoire des 80 quelque
part à contresens marche arrière du coup
on était dans le coin mais la finalité
le suspense les gens veulent savoir est
ce que je lui montrais en pas après tout
à fait une histoire tatras et à tracer
et après il faut savoir quand même que
ensuite quand il m'avait fait un peu
peur je lui mentais c'est à dire que mon
train était genre dans quatre minutes
mais hélas il est dans combien de temps
la tonte rangé dans huit minutes
tout va bien on est large alors voilà on
va faire être mentir sur sur le timing
est très bien on va le voir je viens d
c'est vrai que j'avais déjà doublé le
temps mais je préférais ça et au final
[ __ ] je les ai vus de tubas set et de
dent
oui j'ai sauté dans le train mais
clairement clairement et je rentrais
dans le temps et les portes et envahi
mondiale le temps de se dire au revoir
et j'ai fini mal donc j'ai commencé ma
nuit dans la voiture j'ai pu bouger
après c'est vrai avant de repartir ou au
jeu j'ai dit tiens je me prend cinq
minutes il s'est bien passé cinq heures
je suis arrivé cramé par un soleil voici
la true story 2 du jour avec philippe et
comme tu étais déjà apparu dans la
trousse story de l'ukraine vous vous
rendez compte que j'ai plein d'histoires
avec ce mec
celle ci était la plus valorisante pour
toi que j'avais un temps c'était il ya
quatre ans cinq ans pourquoi on vous
raconte cette histoire parce que comme
quoi ça peut arriver sans faire gaffe et
c'est intéressant de voir quand quand
qu'on ne tague récent pas parce que j'ai
vu le mec qui est dans un schéma de jeu
labour faut que je leur amène et qui
comprend pas pourquoi je veux qu'il
s'arrête
tu voles de trucs pas bon en même temps
on aurait peut-être pu partir un poil
plus tôt oui mais moi je te suivrai
oui je me disais à la région le cadet
que les jeux man de mon pays
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous a plu je vous
recommande vivement de regarder au moins
la dernière vidéo qu'on a fait avec
philippe vous avez mille affiches là
haut je vous mets aussi le lien dans la
description philippe d'un imitateur
performeur vocal je ne sais pas pourquoi
je tapote comme ça comme si on était des
mégapot mais enfin le cds 5 ans qu'on
sait pas plus de cinq ans bah oui
n'hésitez pas à regarder cette vidéo
conférence en vouloir découvrir la
chaîne de philippe d'ailleurs je voulais
mais aussi dans la description
merci donc à vous d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo et je vous dis abonnez-vous à la
chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait et
rendez vous demain à 17 heures
wa ma décharge quand même je suis né
dans le vaucluse mais j'ai pas habiter
dans le vaucluse je suis parisien et
sauf que j'ai vécu quatre ans avec
quatre ans de mon adolescence ce qui
fait que je parcourais toutes ces terres
là et en fait c'était le parisien qui
faisait croire qu'il connaissait le sud
quoi j'ai pas osé lui dire c'est pour ça
que je j'ai pris cette petite voie
rapide dans le mauvais sens